islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
salaam alaikum guys i am back yet again
with another another snippet of our
current affair which is the war between
ukrainia and russia
now
what you see here on my right on my left
is a picture of two christian couple
going to get married in the christian
way or i don't know maybe well baptized
maybe they do that when they're young i
don't know so
i just want you guys to imagine for a
second for a moment let's pause for a
second
just imagine these these pictures are
made up this is not real by the way okay
imagine a palestinian couple getting
married and they're posting saying we've
just got married because we know we're
going to enter the battlefield defending
our country against israel and we might
die in the process so we thought let's
get married what do you think the media
would do what they call them hero would
they call him the uh you know the the
couple that uh has got courage to stand
up and they are getting married what
about if this happened in afghanistan
once again these pictures are made up
they're not real they're they're the two
that were showing about the muslims but
they just made that clear here
what about if this happened in
afghanistan if somebody who was going
there to fight the the army that is
invading their country and they wanted
to go out there and said we wanted to
get married and die together fighting
the oppressors or the invaders
what would the media say
you know and i know what they would say
you know who would be labeled as a hero
courageous brave
and which one will be labeled as a
fanatic terrorist
with these little snippets that's all i
have to say today brother sisters share
this far and wide let the whole world
see the double standards that is going
on right as we speak and racism
till next time assalamu alaikum
we've purchased this huge two thousand
seven hundred square meters building
with this huge seven and a half thousand
square meters of land and insha'allah
with your help we are going to convert
this huge property into the most epic
islamic center in the whole country of
norway now this is a southern cage area
that will keep on giving you rewards for
as long as this masjid stands click the
button to donate whatever you can